awesome Workshop is Professor hi at UC
Bert
thanks so some of you have seen parts of
this if you saw my student David Rose
poster so I'll be talking about there's
some kind of a little bit more
background in context as well
so this is uh I'll be talking about a
toy problem
toy model which I think hopefully will
be interesting
and about over parameterized learning so
let's get into it
what I'm going to start with is just
like a brief motivation most people
might have heard this but some have not
so and make sure everyone's on the same
page
then I'll give our simple model which
I've also started drawing on the board
to take advantage of the board
then I'm going to zoom in and talk about
an interesting story that goes from
regression through classification
and then because this is what we have
cool new result uh about and because
this is information Theory crowd talk
about one of the interesting new tools
we had to develop to do this which is a
new
variant of the Hanson Wright
concentration inequality
so uh this is a table taken from a 2016
paper something inside is 2017 I think
2016 is when it first showed up uh which
is which challenged us and said look we
have a problem in modern deep learning
and the problem is that we have models
which seem to work well in practice
and but they have way too many
parameters in them but I mean way too
many parameters in particular they have
more parameters in them than you have uh
training data
and so this was it was a call to allow
you to rethink how generalization works
if things are working when you have more
parameters than you have mod and you
have examples and what the paper was
really I think did that Yang at all
paper really did was it said not only do
these could these models potentially fit
gibberish they actually can fit
gibberish you can feed it gibberish
labels and they'll still converge and
train happily
but yet when you feed a data that's not
gibberish it will generalize properly so
what's going on how is this working so
this kicked off a huge effort right of
people trying to understand what's going
on
yeah Ben Rector one of one of the
authors of this a bunch of Google
authors uh
were associated with this paper
and so uh
I got into this thinking about it uh
from a combination of how to teach this
stuff properly and how to make this
problem simpler come with a simpler toy
model which would still exhibit this
behavior and let us study it without
having to think about you know giant
neural Nets that we can't understand at
least I can't understand
so here's the basic uh toy model which
involves gaussian features so
everything's going to be like a linear
model
so we have training data which is X Y
Pairs and we're going to assume that all
these X's are effectively featurized as
IAD gaussians now in reality we're going
to think of these things as coming from
a giant joint gaussian with some
covariance Matrix where some directions
are going to be louder than others but
for Simplicity you should just think of
the underlying space of just IAD
gaussians and we'll talk about that
scaling explicitly to make it life
easier
so if you have a regression problem
what's the simplest regression problem
it's a high dimensional X but only one
of them actually matters
okay so just the first one
now we're going to learn a predictor and
we want to predict that X that's the
regression that's the regression problem
so we're going to solve how are we going
to learn something from training data is
we're going to interpolate
now because we have more variables then
we have equations we can satisfy
everything with equality right so now
which which solution you pick we picked
the Min Norm here because like I said
we're talking about the case in practice
where some directions are louder than
others we're going to make that explicit
by having it have some weighting we'll
have some weights these ways you should
think about as these are related to the
underlying eigenvalues of the underlying
covariance Matrix okay that's what this
is but just to simplify the story we're
going to pull them out explicitly as
weights
and so of course we have a test error
just how well do we actually predict the
true thing so we don't know it's
actually the first coordinate again
yeah jointly gaussian we can always
rotate the space so it's the first
coordinate okay
you notice
the section error has like effectively
two components to it which is one
component is
what weight did you actually give to the
first coordinate
if you give too low a weight you're not
going to get it right and the other is
how much weight did you give to all the
coordinates you shouldn't be giving
anyway to at all and so we call the
first one of those the survival term how
much does a true signal survive your
inference process and the other one we
call a contamination term how much are
your predictions contaminated by other
stuff
so in this case the regression you know
we get good generalization if we if all
the signal survives and there's no
contamination Okay so
now it turns out what's interesting is
we want to understand when will this
work
okay so that's the you know when will
this actually give us a good
generalization
so understand this we I have a model
I've drawn drawn up here as well but I'm
going to show it up here
so we have we follow we want to create
an information query style toy model
right and so if you think about the
binary symmetric Channel or the binary
Erasure Channel or the Z Channel you
know the additive White gaussian Noise
Channel just think of this as a cross
between the out of white gaussian noise
Channel and the Erasure Channel in terms
of its Simplicity and it's inspired by
things like spiked models uh in
statistics generally
so we basically say that the underlying
joint gaussian has two kinds of
directions loud directions and soft
directions
the loud directions are you know bigger
and the other ones are smaller in terms
of their eigenvalue here that's just
going to be the squared weight
and we're going to take an asymptotic
picture we're going to let everything
change with the number of training
examples so n is the number of training
examples
and we're going to say that s equals n
to the r where R is something less than
one is the number of loud loud
directions
and D is the total number of directions
is n to the P where p is something
bigger than that
and we also have a parameter Q which
controls how loud the loud ones are
so what's nice about this is this allows
us to ask questions of what values of r
p and Q are such that we will get
successful generalization or not it's a
very you can kind of study this
so you know if you do this it's a
three-dimensional thing so I can only
show you two dimensional slices so here
we just pick a q which is how loud this
stuff is at 0.25 and we can divide
things into two regions right one region
in which the regression error will go to
zero asymptotically as n goes to
infinity and the other one where you'll
a rational will go to one
and so very nice you get these results
and so if you
oh this triangle is impossible under the
definition that I gave right right these
things have to make sense this thing has
to be louder than this so that's just
the yeah the triangle is just the
impossible region
so uh if you've if you've heard about uh
work um that sometimes this goes on we
we called it harmless interpolation when
we introduced it
um
the another term for this is benign
overfitting which is from Bartlett at
all
and you know this is exactly uh telling
us what this region is
and so it turns out what matters here is
a particular number Q Plus R which is
telling you how many favorite features
there are and how favored they are
and basically it says you have to have
enough favoring which is what this Q
Plus R less than one means
so there's an interesting
parallel thing that this is related to
which is what's interesting about this Q
Plus R greater than one less than one so
I'm going to talk about totally
different seeming problem obviously very
related
which is what is the difference between
the eigenvalues you have for the
underlying covariance Matrix and what
are the eigenvalues you get of the
empirical covariance Matrix right you
can imagine just that problem
so it turns out you get two different
kinds of behavior so here I'm the Orange
is the underlying eigenvalues of the
actual covariance Matrix
and the blue is the empirical
eigenvalues so you get two kinds of
behaviors one is this Behavior where you
can see there's a spike and you look at
the empirical eigenvalues and you can
see there's a spike
and the other kind of behavior is that
you see nothing
the underlying covariance Matrix has
some uh favor directions but when you
look at the empirical you see nothing at
all
this is exactly Q Plus R whether it's
greater than one or less than one
so the case when you have benign
overfitting
from the perspective of Bartlett at all
for aggression is the same as when you
can see the spike
and the other case is when you can't
so this seems like a very nice story
great you know very natural thing can
you actually see the underlying
structure the most important part or not
that tells you whether you'll have
you'll be able to actually have recovery
or not seems like a very nice story but
we noticed something
we noticed something that in this toy
model
you can say what happens if you try to
do regression instead of regression you
try to do classification start with the
simplest case of binary now I can't go
into the whole story we are actually
motivated to do all this in part because
we had another model in our pocket which
is a Fourier series model
um and so we could see in that model
that you can get behavior that looks
like this which basically means that
in terms of learning the function you're
doing a pretty bad job but you can learn
its sign
and we saw this thing happening and we
then worked and in this paper uh with my
student
Vignesh who's graduated I mean and uh
Sasha uh
Sasha Belkin and Daniel Sue who were all
at Simon's at the time this was a
Simon's based collaboration that started
we were able to show that you have
different regions associated with this
and in fact you're able to conjecture
the exact location of this region using
another toy model that we have but it
took a lot of work to prove it
and it turns out that binary
classification can actually succeed
provably even when regression fails
which means that you can see a different
region so now before you only had this
region this is where regression worked
and over here regression didn't work
but now it's actually the case that
binary classification will keep working
here
and only not work in this corner this
little corner here nothing works here
everything both with binary
classification and regression work in
here you know regret regression works
but here it does
so already this is interesting something
is not complete in the regression story
something interesting happens in the
classification story
and as we were doing this just for
people uh there's another interesting
effect which happens I'm not going to be
talking about it is that
we found
that over here
we're doing interpolation right we're
learning by interpolations we're getting
everything reading squared error squared
loss
so we proved this for like first versus
squared loss we think wait
classification you don't use Square loss
for classification I mean you do
sometimes but uh you use you know sbms
you use cross-entropy laws use things
like this so we looked at the svm
and it turned out that what happens over
here
is we could prove that
all the training points become support
vectors
so you're just interpolating it's the
same as interpolating
and it turns out that uh
if you use logistic loss
the inductive Vice of logistic loss is
the same as the inductive bias of the
SPM in this regime and so they will also
have
everything becomes support members so
this branched this kind of paper
branched into more things to study so
you interesting power of toy models
right is lets you see things that happen
a phenomenon called support Vector
proliferation you can go read the
students
more work uh in this direction
and so
that's another story but I'm not going
to focus on that story here
but it's an interesting story
so we're like okay good we have this uh
picture of what happened for binary
classification but we might be really
interested in is multi-class
classification where there's lots of
classes and if you look at what's
happening in sort of in the learning
area
you see that we get ever larger data
sets with ever more classes and ever
more complex models so we thought let's
see if we can also have the number of
classes scale asymptotically as well
so let's have now we have another thing
because we can grow the number of
classes we can grow the size of the
model and we can grow the number of
examples Everything grows together
um so before I talk about this there's a
in terms of connections to the real
world we hope you can understand
fact that classification can work in
regimes where regression doesn't has an
interesting Echo with something that
practitioners observe
which is practitioners observe that when
using deep learning models especially
some of the current Transformer style
models even a problem that you would
think of as being naturally a regression
problem people often find themselves
modeling it using classification style
approaches using classification style
losses classification style
architectures to train and it does
better than if you train it like a
regression problem seems weird
but it's people do it
so yeah
this is the regime where learning
calibrated models and
very excellent question
um the question is you know is this the
regime so here you can learn calibrated
models and you're saying that regression
basically forces you to learn a
calibrated model in spirit and here
we're saying well I only want to get the
decisions right but I don't have the
calibration right does that what's
causing this now that's a really good
question I'm not sure right certainly
what we're doing is not calibrated the
question is whether you can actually end
up calibrating it
in this time
also we're doing asymptotics which is
like a we want crisp professional so the
calibration is like a little harder to
exactly quantify so n
okay so let's see what happens as you
look at the multi-class problem
so again can you go back yeah so your
the classes are not growing as fast as
the number of
sharp strong leggings like uh I just was
staring at it for a while yeah yeah so I
drew a picture here to give them so
what's happening is that the number of
actual data points is n the model size
is much bigger the number of directions
that our favorite is smaller than n
and the number of classes is smaller
still we're going to assume that all the
classes are followed
okay for Simplicity we're going to
assume that basically the first K
directions in our arbitrarily chosen
directions each one aligns to a
different slots so the first Direction
aligns to class one so if you think in
the first direction is documents the
second is astronaut use the third one is
you know grass themes right that's what
these features represent
um
and so our in the toy model we're going
to say the label will be assigned the
true label the underlying true label is
whichever one of these label defining
features is the loudest
so if a particular example has more
dogness than it has everything else
we'll label it a dog it's true label
will be dog
so this is the model for how we generate
everything again the idea is to have
analytically clear tractable uh story of
what's going on
and
we're going to learn K different
predictors
and we're going to learn them using
Straight mid-norm style interpolation
with one hot encoding so we're going to
take a y Vector which will be ones in
all the places where we have a label of
dog and zeros and everything that's not
labeled a dog and we'll say just
interpolate this
right
predict ones on all the things that are
dogs predict zeros on everything that's
not a dog for the dog Nest score
okay that's what this is the dogness
score uh and then my prediction time
we'll just calculate the maximum score
between the different classes
now it's interesting
that uh remember I told you how cross
how logistic loss and spms had the same
inductive bias as L2 for the toy model
well long with the Kamara Trump they
proved that for the multi-class the same
thing happens so cross-entropy laws and
um One Versus All svm and L2 in this
regime have identical inductive biases
and they all go to this
so you might think that analyzing Min to
Norm but it's actually this works for
cross-entry retail same thing will
happen
so you can uh you can look at this and
see what happens here
so
we looked at this problem and we said
leveraging so in last year's uh Europe's
we presented a achievability result that
focused on the case of Q Plus R greater
than one which is when regression
doesn't work
we said in this regime what could we
prove and we proved this region this you
can think it's an achievability region
and I've marked these two terms in red
because they came out of our
achievability analysis grinding through
trying to prove it
but they weren't in our conjecture we
have a way of calculating where we
thought the region should be and these
were not there for that so we thought of
this as we think this is looseness in
our result
and in fact what we've been able to do
now
um is I talked about this a little bit
at ITA
um it'll appear one part of it will
appear at isit and we've submitted um
more is we can show that this
conjectured part is actually exactly
correct
that we have a tight Converse and uh
achievability for kind of understanding
what this region is
um right when I say conversations in
Converse but this specific kind of
classification that we're studying this
and the having the error go to one is
the counterpart having a strong Converse
and at isit the result that we're we
have is a weak Converse so it's an
interesting kind of information periodic
uh kind of take on this you get a re
reconverse using one kind of technique
to get a stronger strong conversation to
think about it differently
so what do these regions look like so in
the original paper we had it you know
you can look at this region so this is
the case of T equals zero which means
that the number of classes is staying
constant and so this is we had this
before this is where regression works
this is where our original result could
prove that a cubability result could
prove that classification could also
could work but actually it works all the
way over here in this week and this is
where it doesn't and this agrees with
the binary case
um
if you look at the case when T is
allowed to grow right this is the T it's
not how fast can you grow then you can
see this is the achievability result
that we were able to prove before
without our tightened uh way of doing
the analysis and this is we can get this
entire region now
and these different boundaries actually
have meaning of what they what what they
correspond to so if you think about it
in information Theory when you get
inequalities in rate regions they
usually mean a different kind of
dominating error event
and exactly the same thing is happening
here
so it turns out what happens here is
that
this boundary here which corresponds to
the one minus r term so R is just
T has to stay on this side that's just
by construction
um the 1 minus r corresponds to when the
dominating error event comes from
contamination in your predictions that's
coming from these features here
and when the dominating error event is
contamination coming from over here
that's this other
thing so this is like it's like it's a
rate region in that time that stop
so
how how do we prove the converse and how
do we do it right how does this work
so we have to show that you know like
what is me what is making the problem
harder as we grow the number of classes
so it turns out one of the things that's
making the problem harder is that as we
increase the number of classes if you
have two classes then half of your
training points tell you a positive
example of each of the class
when you have a thousand classes
then only one thousandth of the examples
are giving you positive training
examples every other class investor just
zero
right and so what's it's the sparsity of
the labels
right that's uh causing us in this Min
Normandy so if you think about I'm
interpolating something right and I want
most of this most of the things I'm
trying to predict are zero
you're going to lose signal as a result
of this and so this is what we have to
kind of make rigorous and analyze
um and what happens when these labels
are very sparse is the contamination
becomes uh high and so it ends up
dominated right so that's what it's the
same kind of thing the survival to
contamination ratio is what determines
whether things will succeed
um we said that we have to analyze it
and the achieve really is the flip side
like we when you have the true signal
survives over the contamination then it
turns out that you can also do these
comparisons and succeed
why can you do the comparisons and
succeed it's because gaussian features
have a significant margin
so if you have K different gaussians and
you say which one wins this one wins
which is the second best this one
the difference between the best and the
second best doesn't shrink too fast for
gaussian features and that's what allows
us to you know have to show that we get
achievability
so all of this we have to end up
analyzing
uh
the concentration of bilinear forms why
because what we have here is a Min Norm
interpolation problem and so there's a
we're doing a squared error style thing
so the more Penrose pseudo-inverse that
we have to analyze and there's going to
be a quadratic form that we have to
analyze and to see how fast is this
concentrate
so here I'm going to like start talking
a little bit about these inequalities
which some of you might have seen some
of you have not seen so the classic
Hanson write inequalities for quadratic
forms of the form X transpose MX or M is
some deterministic Matrix for us of
course the Matrix is random but you know
we'll have to grind through analysis to
deal with that
so it says that X transpose MX is a
quadratic form this will concentrate to
its expectation at a certain rate
and what matters here is the of course
the forbidius norm of M because that's
the amount of stuff that you get and you
know
in other other terms that are important
appropriate assumptions sub-gal sanity
and so on
so in in in in earlier work what we did
was we used like this trick
right and for our analysis of binary
um we said hey I can turn uh by linear
form like this into the difference of
two quadratic forms and use Hanson write
on these and kind of keep grinding
through the analysis
there's one more con complication which
is that we get you know things that are
look like this and here
you need
you need M to be a constant relative to
these to how things work so
what that means is you actually
technically you need some kind of
Independence
of course here
you do not have this kind of
Independence
so what did what do we what do you have
to do for these kinds of proofs but this
kind of proves you have to
find ways of massaging and tweaking
things to get the independence you need
so for regression binary classification
we could just use you know Sherman
Morrison kind of rank one updates
inverses to pull stuff out and you know
do manipulation to try to deal with
pull the independent Parts out and say
that those dominate the dependent Parts
don't dominate
or uh
the vector case when you think about uh
the situation when you have
multi-class classification the
dependency structure is more more
complicated
right because the labels depend on all
of the k
label defining features it's not on one
thing so you have to be more careful
but it turned out that when we did our
analysis originally uh at last year's in
Europe's without an improvement in
Hanson right we were we just ended up
getting looseness like fault the
following is solving through
so one of the cool new things we needed
was
new
concentration results on bilinear forms
like this
so it turned out in the literature
um there was some work on getting uh
versions of concentration for this we
had some kind of sparsity assumption and
we have a kind of sparsity assumption so
one of the new inequalities that we
proved that this is at the isit paper
involved explicitly making a sparsity
assumption on why and saying that we
have some Bernoulli sparse Bernoulli
random variable which is entry-wise
multiplying this and we have to deal
very carefully with the kind of
dependencies that this is allowed to
have
so that allowed us to get uh uh nice
results
in the newer work we have a second such
inequality
which you can think about if you saw uh
David's poster uh you can think about
this as
if you have we have a turn off bound
right which uh for exponential Tales you
understand everything
then you have the huffing inequality
which says Ah abounded right but if you
if you want to stay away no actually
know something about the variance of the
random variable then you can use
Bernstein inequality and kind of get
tighter so if you want to think of the
analogy the analogy is classic Hansen
right is like huffing and we wanted the
analogy to Bernstein we had knew
something about the right so that's this
new uh inequality that we have we
basically make an assumption that Y is
soft sparse between my soft sparse we
mean that it's bounded and it has a
variance that's small and if its
variance is small we want to allow for a
better understanding of how fast things
concentrate
okay
so that's it this is from our paper
which will have the extended version
will show up on archive uh
this is the classic Hanson Wright this
is the park uh result where there's an
independence of
this on Independence of of X but not Y
which doesn't work for the situation
that we need because the class depends
on the actual features
um so we have a variant where we say we
could move the independence assumption
and then this is the version where we
just make an assumption on uh scarcity
aboundedness and bounded variance
so
what as I conclude I want to sort of
tell you like what's cool about this toy
model
what's cool is you can actually cast
simple problems it's related to other
things you can see interesting things
come out
and
it turns out that
we're motivated in building this model
by just thinking about what happens in
some classical signal processing analogy
so in the classic classic signal
processing analogy you think about under
sampling
over sampling
right and Nyquist sampling
right Nyquist sampling is the
counterpart of the same number of
equations as unknowns
you can get smoothing if you have faster
than Nyquist sampling but if you have
slower than Nyquist sampling you can get
aliasing but does a listing always kill
you answer is that depends
and so we said actually we were
motivated by this analogy to study the
problem of here and we were able to make
very precise analogy and what's the
analogy like we treat every favorite
feature as well as the low frequency
component we create all of these things
past n as though they're the signs and
cosines that Alias to this under regular
sampling
we treat all Distortion from
non-linearity as though it's noticeable
everyone who has studied signal
processing this is like classical
analysis of quantization error through
uh in DSP we say let's just bring all of
that analysis to get intuition and
that's allows us to make a you know
white sand stationary style analysis so
if you look at the neurops 22 paper
appendix k
um in the supplementary material we work
out how to do this kind of heuristic
calculation which doesn't involve any
concentration inequalities of any kind
to exactly predict quantitatively where
these rate mutants are going to be of
course it's heuristic
you know we assume this is independent
of this well this is a problem with this
well it's not but
what turns out is that the new uh
tighter hence and right inequalities
together other observations on Spectra
allow us to make that style of analysis
much closer to rigorous
um which is nice
so
I want to close with what do you get by
actually getting a tight region for how
interpolating schemes pay
what it does is it lets you now compare
against non-interpolating schemes that
might be natural and it turns out
there's a very natural non-interpolating
scheme for doing classification
and it's like if you think about K memes
right what is k-means inspired by what's
the Exemplar of a class the average of
all positive example examples of that
class
so you could imagine constructing a
score function that's just the average
of all positive examples
right and just looking at the inner
product with that average
friend as your score very clear right
everyone can say this is a natural thing
to try
so you can you can actually figure out
how does that behave if you do an
elementary calculation you'll see that
you'll get
this uh region for generalization
and this region it turns out
exactly matches what we said for one of
the regimes but not for the other
okay so the regimes in which regression
works
where you can see the spike
this is not the same this is a different
the two are separated from each other so
you might ask which is better doing
cross-entropy loss or you know
SPM or you know something that's Min
Norm interpolating like what act so we
can at least say for midnormal
interpolation in that case that it's
worse
where regression works is where this
kind of approach actually does worse
than this naive scheme not interpolating
skin which is also nice let's just uh
kind of think about this no why is this
worse
in the regime in precisely the regime
where a traditional and under where the
understanding of benign overfitting from
the regression would say that that's
where you expect or fitting to be benign
actually in that case for classification
it can hurt you
so I will close here right so I'm happy
to take questions
leave time for a few questions
yes
yeah have you thought about regression
so we started with regression right and
so regression we understand
um but I'm gonna like circle around to
your question right so a better question
exactly what about I'll take a question
broadly what about regression right
so let me go back
okay to this let's go back this region
under the understanding that we have
from Bartlett at all in this analysis
here's where regression works
from in normal interpolation and here's
where regression does work and if you
think about the story
right uh
it seems like a very nice with a bow
tied story like oh you know this is
hopeless this is bad this is good
regression works here it doesn't work
here very nice we just told you
classification will work here okay so
now the question becomes can we get
regression style problems to also work
here by doing something different the
reason I'm asking is that
uh so binary classification the
characterization of binary
classification seems to be different
from multi-class classification
and
and then the
characterization of regression seems to
be then completely different from
classification one idea is to actually
uh
try to look at regression as a
multi-class participation with a lot of
things right but you are saying
y over parametrization hurts for the
multi-classical estimation then I
going back like oh but
uh yeah I think I think you're exactly
right I think this is exactly what we
think needs to be studied next right is
that so we we're studying the problem
kind of from first bottom up right so we
make the simplest possible census
orthogonal classes assumption
when you try to take a regression
problem and turn it into a
classification problem you don't have
orthogonal classes instead you have so
you think about orthogonal classes as
orthogonal signaling it is kind of like
how you think about
um no bandwidth constraint communication
um this is actually the bandwidth
constrained setting where you have to
put constellation points down in one
space and that's a different problem
and so that deserves that right actually
yeah we think we think that this there's
like a next thing to study which might
be able to kind of refine our
understanding even the projection itself
and might challenge the approaches to
training that
we're currently studying might say that
there's actually something better we can
do
alternatively it might support why
deeper networks work better in practice
one of those two so this is the but what
I'm trying to sell here for everybody is
like you know it's worth looking at
things from the bottom up using simple
models because then your insights that
you learn and where the effects are are
very sharp you know this and then you
then you can push next if you only work
on things that are
very general all your results will
sometimes be somewhat squishy and you
won't know where to where to where to
press on them and that's the
right
instance more
thank you um